-Our next guest is
the award-winning host
of "The Graham Norton Show."
The second season of his show,
"Queen of the Universe,"
will premiere on June 2nd
on Paramount Plus.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend from across the pond,
Graham Norton, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome.
-Thank you very much.
-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
This is a big deal for us.
-Wow. That's -- Yeah, that's --
[ Cheering ]
It's impressive
that they can cheer
and whoop like that
while Googling me.
-Oh, no, no, no.
See, you don't realize
you're a big deal over here
and people are very excited.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheering ]
-I think a lot of them think
they would have to
cross the Atlantic to see you.
-Take a plane.
-And now they get you here
in person.
-Here I am.
-Here you are.
-And I'm very happy to be here.
I love New York City.
I think it's very good
for old people fun.
-Oh, wow. Interesting.
Meaning what?
-Well, you know,
my days of daytime clubbing
and zip-lining, they're over.
-And you were
very good at them both.
-I loved them.
-Were you a zip liner for real?
-No.
-Okay.
-You went to some clubs
in the daytime, though.
-That I did, too.
-Yeah.
-So now I'm here,
and, you know,
you can go to see shows.
There's galleries.
They deliver things.
It's easy to get a cab.
It's old people fun.
And if you are
an older thrill-seeker,
you can be excited
by maybe being hit by a bike,
because that gets
your heart rate up.
-That's the new zip-line.
-Yeah, that is it.
-Yeah.
Ooh! Where's my medication?
-You obviously, you usually
are asking the questions.
How do you feel about
being the interviewee
as opposed to the interviewer?
-I mean, not great,
to be honest --
[ Laughter ]
So sorry, apologies in advance.
That bit's so much easier.
It's so much easier to be you.
-I agree.
I just did James Corden's
show last week,
and I genuinely said to him,
"Being the guest
is so much harder."
-Really, really hard.
So bear that in mind.
[ Cheers ]
This is very difficult.
[ Applause ]
-And I think that, you know,
sometimes I'll have people,
often will be on the show
and when it's over,
they'll lean over and go, "How
do you do this every night?"
And I'm like, doing it
every night is the easy part.
Doing it once every six months,
that's the hard part.
-Yeah, no, I remember
when I was growing up,
there was a show in Ireland
called "The Late Late Show,"
and I mean,
it started about 7:00, but...
but it was dark out, so...
And there was
a host called Gay Byrne.
That was actually his name.
And he did it forever.
The show is still going.
And as a kid, I always dreamt of
being a guest on the show
and it's only as an adult,
I've realized it's much better
to be the host,
because you get to be
on every week.
And also, you know,
the chances of you
coming back are higher,
because --
you know what it's like.
When you started this show,
there were probably guests
you really wanted to get.
-Now, not so much.
-Yup, exactly.
The longer you do it,
you want it --
you start repeating people
and other people
sort of get
dropped off the ledger.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But the thing
that I'm very impressed with,
because I do think you have a
harder job as a host than I do,
is you have to navigate
multiple guests out at once.
And it's sometimes
as many as six people.
Also six very famous people.
Do you get nervous
about that part of it?
-Well, sometimes.
But I think what's good
about actors is -- no offense,
but sometimes they don't
care about an audience.
-Right.
-But they do care
about each other.
-I see.
-So if an actor
tells a funny story,
you can see someone seething,
kind of like,
"I have a funny story!
I [bleep] myself!"
And so the stakes
get higher and higher.
Sometimes we do get, like,
terrible stories,
like, don't tell that
on television!
-Well, that is fascinating,
because I will say,
in my head,
when I think of famous people
and the most embarrassing story
they've told on a chat show,
it's always on yours.
-But I think that is
because of the other guests.
They're trying to outdo
each other.
And also it is funny to say
something really rude
in front of Dame Judi Dench
or something.
-And I do believe she is
someone a perfect example.
She knows the role she plays.
-Yes.
-When someone says something,
she knows to
lean into the Dame
in those moments.
-Absolutely. "Ooh!"
-Do you ever -- I always,
if I ever get nervous --
I think the longer
I do the show,
the less I get nervous,
which is wonderful.
But it is the sort
of very famous people,
especially famous people
when I was young,
and you tend
to get a lot of those.
Do you get nervous anymore
with people like that?
-I mean, sometimes.
Backstage, we were talking
about Tom Cruise.
-Yeah.
-And Tom Cruise is one
of those people, you know --
Because normally once
they come through that door
and they sit down,
pretty quickly,
it's just a man in a jacket
or some woman in a frock,
and that's the end of it.
Tom Cruise, I never get past
the fact that it's Tom Cruise.
He remains Tom Cruise
throughout the interview,
and an audience likes that,
and I enjoy that,
and also, you know,
the other guests, you can tell
they're all a bit starry
about him,
and there aren't many people
like that.
That kind of old star system's
kind of gone.
-It's really funny
how you would say,
"Oh, there's no
movie stars anymore.
There's just great actors
and actresses."
And then every now
and then you're like,
"Oh, I just saw
a [bleep] movie star."
Like, they come out,
the audience is different.
It's really, it's a trip.
-Like, Jennifer Lopez
is not everywoman.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-It's so funny
that she played a maid.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, right.
-When you come on
another one
of these shows like this,
do you sort of check out
the green rooms?
Are you measuring them up
compared to yours?
-I have to say, already now,
I have to go back to London
and I may have
to change my ways.
A handwritten note
from Seth Meyers.
-I should note I learned
the handwritten notes,
that was a gift given to me.
Jimmy Fallon told me, "Make
sure, when you get this job,
you leave a --"
So I leave a handwritten note
every day. Yeah.
[ Crowd awws ]
-See, what's sweet is,
I used to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-So this isn't a thing
you didn't know about.
You just stopped.
-I just stopped.
It's like, very nice of you
to swing by the dressing room,
say hello.
Don't do that anymore, either.
-You don't even say
hi to the guests?
-What's the other thing
I don't do?
Oh, talk to them afterwards.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
No, no.
If I bump into them
in a corridor, I'll say hello.
-Oh that's lovely.
-Yeah.
-I mean,
that's above and beyond.
-Sometimes, though,
I don't recognize them,
and I'll think,
"They're well dressed."
[ Laughter ]
-I once saw -- A young person
on the street said hi to me,
and I panicked and I thought
they had been a young actor
who'd been on the show
and I'd forgotten.
And we were waiting
for the light.
So I leaned in and I go,
"So what have you been up to?"
And they looked at me and go,
"Just getting ready for finals."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Cool, cool.
That's a normal question
that a man my age asks."
-Yeah. "You busy right now?"
-Hey, I got a lot
more questions.
You guys, that's Graham Norton!
We'll be right back.